yo it's hoving hilton brooklyn zone
check me out on the bullet kev podcast
yeah
bullet cat podcast special guest in here
ho vayne what's up my brother welcome
welcome welcome welcome man thank you
for having me man it's good to see you
man um
good to see you keep doing your thing
likewise i met you you was here then you
went to another place everywhere you go
you win that's bouncing around all you
do is win yes for sure you're bouncing
around but you're not bouncing down well
i've been i've been in l.a now since
2017 early 2017. he's bouncing around
you're not bouncing down not bouncing
down is what is important my friend
and uh same with you i feel like you
keep leveling up leveling up leveling up
i try to man god is good man you know
it's crazy because i feel like you know
when you're good people and you have
good relationships like no matter what
transpires like you're always going to
end up
on time i feel like if you work hard
you're a good person keep your face
clean you believe in god anything can
happen yeah
it's crazy too because you would even do
you
remember when you were starting to
interview artists didn't you do a rick
ross interview i did a girl's interview
that went crazy it went viral tmz
everywhere didn't you i want to get back
to that yeah i was gonna say you you
like like
i did a couple i did five i did
charlemagne i did lenny s i did ross i
did gz and i did um
wex who was the head of adidas at the
time
for people who uh don't know who you are
kind of give us a breakdown who is joe
vane what do you do i'm a talent manager
and i'm a music executive i'm a
doc connector as much as you are a doc
connector yeah like a lot of times like
i have relationships and i have
respectable relationships with people
somebody might call me like hey you know
this person oh hey do you know somebody
at nike could you put me together or do
you know this person do you know
somebody mercedes and i just facilitate
it and i just put put the two parties
together
what is um
some of your talent roster that you work
with on a regular basis obviously you
work with cinematic and johnny scheid
cinematic johnny shapes that's the home
you know i'm the president of cinematic
management company we have uh paris
bryant who's in the house right now
um we have
uh well i have styles p
i have lloyd banks um spinner benz
um [ __ ] kb mike
a bunch of artists
like hell locale
um
[ __ ] we was managing t-pain for a little
while
uh joey badass was with us for a minute
um i had wallet for a second busta runs
does it get to a point where you can be
managing too many artists at once no
because it's a team you know what i'm
saying it's not like it's not like
you're the soul yeah it's not like i'm
the sole you know what i'm saying so
like if i delegate properly i have
somebody that's gonna be in place with
them and all i gotta do is make the call
or whatever you know what i'm saying
it's never i don't think it's too many
too many people because i feel like
sometimes you'll see like somebody like
they'll have like
six artists their manager and they're
like but they were like handling a lot
of it on their own yeah that's that's
almost impossible it's not enough time
in the day if you want to give people
the the proper proper attention they
deserve you got to have a team so i'm
lucky and blessed that i have a team of
great people that work with me 100 man
um
how did you initially kind of get your
foot into the music game like take us to
the beginning of like your career [ __ ]
at the beginning i just had one artist
like you know my homeboy he was rapping
and it kind of like
the situation called for a manager and
it was just like all right cool you're
the manager so from there that was like
the origin of you just getting involved
in the industry period yeah 100 we start
we started bsb yeah we started music
[ __ ] together i feel like managing
artists is like
kind of like a blanket statement a lot
of people make in terms of like yeah i
managed an artist or i do a r [ __ ] or
okay give me kind of like
if you're an artist manager what are
your tasks like what is like define that
for me
you have to you have to enhance the
situation whatever they have going on
like so a lot of times people come up to
you and be like hey i need management
and i'm like you don't really have
anything to manage yet you know what i'm
saying there's no demand there's no
deals to make there's no interest
there's no
revenue that need to be brought in so
you don't need a manager and i'd
probably
assess their situation and tell them
what they do need right a lot of people
don't need management to get to a point
where there's something to manage
so but so essentially you're just
putting gasoline on whatever fire's
already yeah and you're using your your
your leverage and your relationships to
take it to another level like if you
come to me and you're seven
my job is to make you a ten you know
what i'm saying maximize and build your
talents and give you my tutelage and
show you the way to be a the best artist
you could possibly be a manager is like
a bridge to your up to the other side of
your potential you know what i'm saying
so you might be making a hundred
thousand a year a month let me show you
and do these things with so we could
maximize that and now we're making 500
000 a month you know what i'm saying
give you a bunch of strategies and a
bunch of disciplinary tools to get to
where you need to go but at the end of
the day it's the artist and the talent
that is the driving the ship you know
what i'm saying i'm just kind of like
siri that's got you got you is it you
know what it's crazy too because dealing
with artists it's not a magic button
people think managers are a magic button
like it's also well i think what it is
is what some people [ __ ] up is they get
a manager and then they stop doing the
work that's not it that's what i'm
saying the artist is the car
the manager is the gps the gps
make this road smoother lead you to the
right way guide you you know you're
going to track now this is the way we
need to get to where we need to get to
or show you exactly like some people
don't even have a plan for themselves so
i'm going to show you
where you and your talent can get you to
and this is the way we need to do it to
get to this part you almost want um
an artist who kind of self-manages as
well
if that makes sense yeah 100 because
something i i mean like i've seen it
where there's like people who
they really need their hand held through
every little step of the way and every
artist is different some people need a
little more handheld than others some
people are totally self-sufficient and
some artists are like
you know
they need
they call it the morning yo get up you
know you have a thing today or your
flight his itinerary some people i could
just shoot the text and like yo i'm on
my way there and the artist might be
like oh man already you know what i'm
saying so yeah so you just play it by i
guess you just kind of play it it's a la
carte there's no one managing style that
fits every artist
that's real that's that's that's fair
um
for you like if if someone's watching
this who's like a up and coming rapper
up and coming singer
like there's so many
what is that noise
oh is it the is it is it coming in from
that room
is that the ufc fight yeah i was like
is that what that is
yeah oh yeah you'll see on youtube i'm
like what the [ __ ] is going on i'm like
is it sportscenter been playing in my
ear
um no but just in terms of like
you know the music industry is always
changing
um you know we always hear about like
i was just saying like uh south by
southwest is next week and i'm like man
you know how many young up and coming
artists about to get taken advantage of
next week
used to be a jungle they're gonna drop a
bag on some shitty stage that ain't
gonna do nothing for them but in terms
of like the things that you see
artists making mistakes with maybe like
financially because nowadays
you can't buy your way onto playlists
you can buy streams that [ __ ] is not
sustainable though you can fake the funk
that's not sustainable you go you can do
all these things right say like you buy
streams and then you have to actually go
out on the road and go on a tour and you
can't sell no tickets so it doesn't
equate all right you got
seven million monthly listings but you
can't fill the philip 500 cap room right
like you can fake it but eventually the
proof is in the pudding on the back end
are you guys able to see if someone's
full of [ __ ] with their streams 100 we
know
you know
so let's say you guys are interested
have you ever been interested in an
artist and saw their metrics and been
like oh that okay the music is dope but
then check their numbers and they were
fugazi you check their numbers and
the eye test doesn't fool you start to
look you like though the comments don't
match
x amount of people are not talking about
this especially on the youtube is very
telling
well if you if you got fake youtube
views it's so you can see it and then
even if you got a bunch of comments if
they're [ __ ]
russian bots or whatever you're like
yeah like if you really do your homework
you don't just get blinded by numbers
you dig a little deep and you have some
type of common sense about you you could
tell you you look you'd be like nah
that's not real ah
you know when something feels real like
you've been imposed you you've been in
this game long enough to know when
something's wrong oh for sure yeah and
you have enough relationships and
friends in certain markets like if
something's going on there you're gonna
call me oh is this heating up out here
and like i would do that for you and
marcus
right right right and you'll be like nah
no i don't know i never heard it i'll be
seeing this [ __ ] all the time bro
someone was saying hey yo i got three
million views on my video and i'm
checking this [ __ ] out like 11 comments
i'm like bro
it's nasty it's just put the work in man
just put the work in but i mean then you
have other the other side of the coin
where you'll hear artists saying that
even major labels are beefing up the
numbers are juicing the numbers they've
been it's not we act like we didn't know
record labels used to buy copies when it
was vinyls and cds back in the day
there's nothing new it's just a digital
age it's easier the same thing yeah they
used to go buy out record stores and try
to get yo look what's his projections yo
he's gonna be a hundred thousand short
of doing number one yo we gonna go buy
those it's gonna be sitting in the
warehouse somewhere and we're gonna do
it this is nothing new this is they've
been doing it mm-hmm regularly we've
been doing this same new [ __ ] it's just
in a digital format yeah how do you um
you know i think the biggest thing that
like is like a wall that a lot of
rappers will hit that they maybe don't
necessarily understand
is the playlist [ __ ] is the spotify [ __ ]
it's like it feels like um
almost i'm sure for a lot of artists
like an impossible task to get on some
playlists
i think i i tell artists all the time
man don't focus on getting the attention
of
uh industry people and playlisters focus
on one fan a day you know what i'm
saying you focus on growing your fan
base you might have 10 fans cater to
them and grow them fans don't focus on
nothing outside of your control because
all you're going to end up getting is
taken advantage of by people who say i
can
get you on this playlist yeah because if
you if you focus on the fans
and you build i mean that all that other
shit's going to come it's going to come
but if you're not they're going to see
oh he got a crazy following let me put
him on this playlist because it's going
to help us you know i mean i think that
i think i think russ is somebody who
probably initially had that perspective
because he used to just he always talks
about
jeans how he used to email all the blogs
and they would never give him no [ __ ]
attention and then once he started just
focusing on
his world space he could control it
sounds so corny and cliche like i be
telling people stuff and like even like
i teach a college class and i'll be
telling people like yo what you getting
you getting what you put out you you get
what you put in like it's the creation
of the truth it's the truth
don't focus on
people like yo how can i get your
attention big dog don't worry about me
get the fans up and when fans start
going crazy i'm going to see it and i'm
going to come holla at you don't focus
on getting nobody in the music but
people do that because they think if i
have you it's going to be easy no just
do the work focus on your fan base
making or organic fans
creating organic fan interactions
focus on growing your merch base having
people
trained that they have to buy stuff from
you focus on uh doing shows locally and
growing your shows and selling hard
tickets training your fan base to do
that and just grow it don't focus on
getting attention no music industry
person or no playlist
yo
talk about like
for you
the
transparency between the artists and
like
major record labels and what a major
record label deal
would look like typically has been like
as high as ever you see like meek mill
talking about it yg talks about it nba
young boy just called that atlantic
records like for a month straight and
then did like my thing is like
it
if you're
you kind of give people like an idea
because i don't think a lot of people
understand like how an advance works and
i think all those artists who give it
it's a loan it's a loan it's a shitty
loan it's a loan very shitty it's
because if i if i finance a house for
you right you buy a house
after you pay it back you own the house
right mm-hmm yeah even after you that
money is recouped that's the worst it's
the worst [ __ ] yeah so a loan a loan is
like
a advance is just alone with like you
said shitty terms but a lot of times
these artists are in destitute and
impoverished situations so they're going
to take anything and sign anything it's
not the labels fault per se it's a
little predatory it's predatory
it's predatory but that's why you're
supposed to have
a good lawyer or a manager yeah yeah i
think i can't i can't afford nobody for
falling for anything you signed because
you signed it there's layers between
like when megan like the whole megan
thing with uh carl crawford's going i'm
like yo you signed yeah it's a deal and
you're supposed to have management and
you're supposed to have a lawyer who
looks out for that if you failed those
two things you got to say you know what
i hired the wrong team and i signed the
wrong deal it was my fault is the label
who's gonna do what the labels gonna do
they've been doing this it's not nothing
new you getting tricked by antics that
they they did since the start of music
this people was complaining about deals
and contracts in the 1940s yeah so it
was like you see this but you decide to
forgo that or you don't have the right
people to explain it to you and you sign
that deal and if it's [ __ ] up you have
to be a man or a woman to say yo my team
that i hired
or my team that was given to me that i
didn't investigate
allowed me to sign this and i [ __ ] up
it's [ __ ] up and i wanted to change
but don't say yo they took advantage of
me they gave you something that they
would give anybody and they
also i mean
you took the you took the bat like my
thing is yeah that's what i'm saying
like you know what when you was [ __ ]
up and you had a hundred dollars in your
pocket and they told they was gonna give
you events of seven hundred thousand you
was like give it to me i'm gonna sign it
you know what i'm saying that's like
people figure out the rest later there's
like people who have a bad attitude at a
store but like yo when you were at your
job interview i'm pretty sure you
weren't like this you were really happy
this is like
like what like the [ __ ] meek mill be
saying i'm like yo meek every time you
turn in an album
you know your advances in the seven
figures
so it's like you know what it is like i
don't know what a meek mill album is
worth nowadays from the labels
perspective he's at least he's at least
getting uh at least
two to five
but like i also think though you can
outperform your contract i definitely
feel like so so if you outperform your
contract they like there should be some
sort of clause where i believe there
should be almost like almost like uh
sports i believe the contract ain't up
yet but we need to renegotiate let's
let's keep it fair tyler murray right
now yeah let's calamari let's let's keep
it fair because some of these artists
they sign these deals when they're when
they're young when they're unknown
they're unknown they're in a [ __ ] up
situation give me the bag and then like
who said it's predatory of the label
they might make this label hundreds of
millions of dollars y'all could say you
know what
we gotta switch this up
let's adjust this let's be fair but
there's nobody to hold the music people
accountable for that like it's just yeah
there's a very few people who do that
kind of show i feel like ships is the
kind of guy who will do that shapes is
like yo you know what
we need to fix this up you know what i'm
saying i'm very artist friendly let's
let's fix this deal up you know what i'm
saying no in terms of like you want
people to stay with you too yeah you and
you want to be you just want to be a
good human being a fair person like yo
listen i'm all for getting money i love
getting money getting money it gives you
freedom to do the things you need to do
but you don't want to take nothing from
nobody else out of somebody else's
pocket i'm saying like let that person
get what they earned and what's fair to
them as well
um
who's been uh for you like
you know i think during the pandemic
there's been like some mvps man
on the rapper side who who's kind of
been your pandemic mvp [ __ ]
pandemic mvp
man i don't know i don't know
it's been a couple mvps
the hands down mvp of the pandemic has
been versus versus the knights and
versus
no de-nice early on for sure he had it
but now but the verse
until until the feats yeah
shout out to your legend feats yeah the
legend fees uh he he was probably him
tory lanez was it um
i just mean in terms of like uh
i think i don't know i look at guys like
um
i think freddy's up there conway's up
there oh i mean conway's gonna do
whatever i just mean like yo like yeah i
just feel like like
output as artists like oh
i don't know man it wasn't nobody that
really sees the moment that grabbed it
like that put a feeling or
uh like when we look back a little baby
maybe yeah but little baby was hot
before nah but i feel like it just went
to another level he was high before he's
gonna be hot after little baby is
special i'm i'm just saying like there's
nobody that 10 years from now we're
going to look back and like yo this is
the sound of those two years true maybe
kendrick could drop out and it embodies
i think i feel like i feel like we're
past it i feel like it has it they
dropped they dropped the mask mandate in
l.a i said all right fine
is it is it mandated in new york still
they just dropped it on the 7th they
just are are you still a knicks fan are
you a nets fan that's baby brooklyn so
you drop you drum [ __ ] i've been a
brooklyn nest fan for since they came
the day they came to brooklyn the day
are you sure it was the day i went to
the first game
first game shout out to adidas shot the
uh john wexler was at their first game
in the adidas suite so first day
uh when they came to brooklyn i'm
rocking with them
i'm from brooklyn before i'm from new
york
what's up with um everyone who was on
bsb
i don't know do you want to talk to
anybody
lito no little's my little that's the
crow i love leto man
he just started doing music again yeah
what the [ __ ] he lito had lito
running around man little had to get get
get his self together he got himself
together now he back at it he kind of
fell out of love for music you know that
makes sense he was like yo i'm good
he
i don't want to talk about his money but
he did a good place so it was like you
know what i'm saying he got in a good
place and he's like man [ __ ] music but
now he kind of itching would you would
you manage leto again 100 i love leto
100 that's that's like whenever whenever
he ready you hit that little whenever
you're ready it's good to go yeah
whenever you're ready it's a certain
people that like you know yo we got to
take a break in the interview real quick
tell you about our folks at my bookie
man this is my favorite time of the year
to gamble i love gambling on sports and
if you've been thinking about putting
your toe into the pool come and join me
at my bookie okay right now we're doing
a promotion and my bookie is crazy when
you sign up for a new account and you
make your first deposit they will match
that deposit up to a thousand dollars it
is march madness the ncaa tournament is
here the brackets is getting filled out
what i need y'all to do also is go on to
my bookie when you sign up they got
their my bracket promotion going on it's
pretty crazy so essentially you sign up
for my bracket first place grand prize
winner gets a bitcoin a whole bitcoin
second place get some crazy ass nft
that's worth a [ __ ] ton of money i don't
know [ __ ] about nfts third place hundred
thousand dollars in cash and prizes so
what are you doing go to my bookie right
now man get in on some of this march
madness some of this nba action i wonder
what the odds were on tom brady coming
back from retirement sheesh
mybookie.ag use that promo code bootleg
b-o-o-t-l-e-g one word when you sign up
and your first deposit will be matched
up to a thousand dollars in free money
let's get back to the interview for
young managers watching this who um
maybe have an undiscovered talent that
they're trying to break like
whoever it might be whatever city it
might be and what would be advice you'd
give them um formulate a team that's one
like you need a team you need a social
media person
uh social media digital marketing you
need a cameraman you need a producer you
need an engineer you need a pr person
the pr person can come a little bit
later on when is when you need it
formulate a team and start building
create a plan and stick to it don't have
no plan b's believe in god keep it fair
keep it ethical and work don't take
everything on by yourself no it's not
it's impossible yeah it's impossible you
have a team you know what i'm saying you
have people when pr come when when does
the because you know a lot of times i
think i see artists do the pr thing too
soon as needed i would say as needed
just like like cooking you you know you
know
at what they say to taste
to taste when needed when when you get
to the point where your faces need to be
seen in your city and you need to be at
every party and you need to be in the
mix you need to know the right [ __ ] then
you get a pr when people are calling
asking for interviews for you and [ __ ]
like that then you need a pr until then
you don't need it but the other things
you need you need a videographer
trailing you every day studio sessions
you need an engineer you need a producer
and um you need a digital marketer and
when after you get to that point you
need a playlister what's a digital
marketer somebody who like you know you
see these things on these websites our
generation
getting you that those looks you see you
think you should just happen organically
like of course
yeah so there's somebody who has a
relationship with these people they're
kind of like somebody who's to work
radio records at radio that relationship
across the country with the dj's what is
a playlister a playlist there's somebody
who helped you get on playlist and i'm
saying they have a user curated playlist
as well because user curated playlists
are very important they're kind of like
a 100
all these things cost money everything
so save your money what is that a dollar
like a like you know let's say what's
the minimum dollar amount somebody
should like try to save up before they
really start trying to build that [ __ ]
out because that's those aren't cheap
things to put together i mean
you gotta maybe you might be able to get
a free videographer
somebody's starting out that's right
that believes in you right the same with
your engineers same with the producer
they all believe in each other
playlisting and the digital marketing
though
so what's that dollar amount you think
minimum
a good digital guy is going to be at
least
at least
1500 2500 a campaign okay and you're
gonna need money to actually give that
person
to run the campaigns you know we're
gonna your incentive we're gonna do it
we're gonna see these videos out and
we're gonna do this content and it's
going to cost x amount we're going to
buy this amount of google
play you know what i'm saying so you
need actual money to give that person
will the digital marketer handle your
youtube ads yes okay a good one which is
important yeah trueview trueview what's
true of you trueview is like
the it's like when you see
say a snoop dogg video come on and after
it uh right into it a yg somebody video
come on like something that's very
similar algorithms you want to piggyback
off that algorithm you know what i'm
saying so when you see a high
performing video video that comes right
after it you know what i'm saying that
makes sense
so
we think about five five bands let's say
i want to drop a single if you want to
drop a single you drop a project single
single i say you should have ten
thousand dollars ten thousand ten
thousand dollars and that's
low that's on the low end make sure your
singles mix and mastered make sure you
got money to shoot a decent video you
get a decent video shot for cheap you
know yeah yeah yeah get a decent video
shot for cheap
um
then you need somebody who's going to
work it at the playlist
level you know what i'm saying
somebody's going to service it well
there it is
and then another person on the team when
you really you see how your team gets so
big damn why this person got all these
people you need somebody who's gonna
pitch your [ __ ] for saints too the
movies and tvs that's a that's a bag as
well a sink person
the sink thing is uh
because they work off of commission a
lot of them so it's like if they don't
get you nothing yeah if they'll get you
know you're planning nothing but so so
these people you're talking about
if someone's in wichita kansas and they
don't know any how do they find how do
you find these people [ __ ] if you're in
wichita kansas you gotta go where these
people are you gotta go to new york
gotta go to l.a yeah that's like any job
if i'm trying to be an actor i'm you
gotta get the [ __ ] out of what you're
talking good chance that i'm not gonna
be actor in wichita i'm gonna have to
move to l.a or new york to come get
noticed so i mean if you take your crab
seriously you gotta go where the people
are are you
the type of uh manager who will
work with an artist
based strictly on how good the music is
and
maybe there's no numbers behind 100 i'm
not a number chaser sometimes you got to
go with your feeling it's like baseball
like everything's now is like
not by the coach can't really call is
all analytic basically sorry analytic
base yeah money ball [ __ ] yeah
that's not how you
you feel a star like you get that
quality when you see them when you meet
them you know i'm saying watching them
interact with people watching them
perform so that can't be just dictated
by numbers you know i'm saying that's a
feeling that is i mean that's real i
think that you want to do a mix you want
to be a hybrid
you definitely don't want to start i
know me at this point i'm too busy to
start with artists who are at a zero
so if you're at a four or five i could
help but if you got 12
instagram followers yeah it's like i i i
can't do that and there's other managers
at this point that can and are willing
to do have you done that where like
someone will come to you and you're like
yo i see the potential but i can't take
this on right now every day let me lob
this to somebody else okay who's like
everyday who's like uh some of the other
managers that you [ __ ] with that you
man's a lot i don't want to leave nobody
out they get offended oh i [ __ ] with a
lot of bandages man uh
who's who's your big homie in the
manager game see i don't really have a
big home he has somebody i looked up to
immensely rest in peace chris lighty but
like i don't have no big homie it wasn't
no in terms of just like somebody who
mentored you nobody nobody like you know
what i'm saying uh at the time when i
was really trying to understand music i
wasn't around a bunch of managers i was
lucky with luckily enough around a bunch
of executives like i was hanging with
sycamore every day we were going to hop
crib
joey ie and tom oscar was used to let me
send an office
at asylum like picking up on deals and
what's going on and [ __ ] like that i
wasn't a rental manager
um
well uh like wayne oh wayne was not a
manager no more great guys love wayne oh
love wayne these are my friends like the
people the people of the culture that's
i love wayne oh man yeah was a great guy
yeah yo we gotta stop the interview real
quick shout out to our presenting
sponsor odd socks baby hey man listen
all i keep on my ass is odd socks draws
all i keep on my feet are socks you know
why because they're the most comfortable
socks in the world and i'm not just
saying this because they promote the
podcast i'm telling you the socks are
crazy uh they got all the licenses look
they got halloween socks they have back
to the future socks
they got [ __ ] twizzler socks
old dirty bastard socks r.i.p to odb all
right they also got their draws if you
want to wear some underwear with pizza
on them whatever you need but my
favorite are the odd socks basics baby
these are just the plain boys these to
me are the most comfortable socks in the
world all right
so trust me when i say go to
oddssoxofficial.com
thank me later when you go to check out
find the most comfortable socks in the
world
get some wwe socks too i just saw a
sneak peek of the new wwe line and
they're [ __ ] insane
in [ __ ] sane uh go to
oddssocksofficial.com use the promo code
bootleg kev that's one word together
bootleg kev
we should talk to them about shortening
that bootleg cab is the promo code you
will get 20 off at checkout one more
time go to oddssoxofficial.com save 20
off using that promo code bootleg kev
let's get back to the interview
obviously you work with cinematic but
would you ever start your own imprint
again um
yeah you see the dope thing about how
the deal is with shapes like
i have i still have my own management
outside like yeah it's like banks and
stuff styles away from cinematic yeah
whole van doing good management so you
know what i'm saying like i manage
people on the outside of that so i never
stopped having my own thing i mean just
like a record label though oh record
label
that's i think that might be my next
phase like finding an artist and really
just breaking them i think that might be
my next phase i think how you see
artists
oh no or you see executives kind of like
doing that nowadays like the topmost
school is how he's with gucci and leor
how he's with doug how do you have one
guy that might that might be my next
phase like finding artists and signing
him to me and that might be my next name
shout out to hovain uh where are you
teaching at kingsborough community
college i teach a college course on the
business of music once a week no not
once a week no more it's semester
semester baseball's
10 weeks a 10 week semester so i did it
two times i'm doing it again we're
coming back in the middle of april and
i'm gonna have nothing but female uh
guest hosts oh fire yeah last semester i
had charlemagne beat out rob markman
shipes did it was this in person around
zoom on zone because of course much
easier to get yeah it's easier hop on
the zoom real quick yeah yeah so i used
to be every monday for 10 weeks uh hour
and a half class so i talked to the kids
about different [ __ ] i have shapes
coming to them talking about
entrepreneurial [ __ ] be that talking to
them about podcasts and the media right
talking to them about journalism right
right they learned every aspect of the
music i had our cfo come talk to them
about uh mechanical royalties and
payments and like they learned
every aspect of of music so this this
semester i'm going to have nothing but
female female managers a r's you know
what i'm saying you know it's crazy
because you mentioned the royalties and
mechanicals and all that [ __ ] i do feel
like the pub side of the music industry
it's unknown well it's the most it just
feels like the most confusing 100 you
know i i sit down with my cfo at the cfo
of our company and he too gives me like
a class
to myself i'm still learning as a as
somebody who's been in this game and you
know what i'm saying there's certain
things that he told me that i don't
really fully understand and i go home
and do some homework and read on it like
hey what can i read can you show me some
contracts that you know i'm saying it's
a lot to learn and you have to want to
learn it that's why i'd be saying like
you can't let nobody take advantage of
you because the information is out there
you just gotta yeah go on youtube yeah
bro bruh everything university
everything is on youtube yeah like it's
the matter if you want do you wanna sit
there and do you wanna do you wanna yes
that's really all it is you want to
entrust in someone to tell you and that
person might be dishonest or they might
not know like information is free man
and i'm the person i like to learn i'm a
teacher and a student
yeah man that's i think a lot of people
that like i feel like the internet has
removed all excuses there's no reason
for you not to know anything i tell my
daughters all the time don't tell me i
don't know there's no reason you don't
know something that's some real [ __ ] man
that's some real [ __ ] well listen whole
vane is there anything else you got
coming oh man just um
got a bunch of music coming this year
from all of my artists stay tuned
see you at the smokers club fest four
what was that is that the twentieth four
thirty or four thirty okay look at
thirty that's in l.a where's his
headline in his headline i don't even
know where's headliner because lupe
fiasco was doing the whole food and
liquor they just added chief keef but
he's doing it it's a smoker's club show
and it's in april where's this
headlining yeah no i'm saying like it's
going to be crazy
he's the first name on the flyer yeah
yeah there's a lot of headliners man
i'm happy to get back on the road this
year
it's gonna be a lot of good things man
uh maybe you're gonna try to get in the
podcast game i want to man i just gotta
make time i want to bring best seat in
the house back i definitely want to have
you on and you talk about your story
because your story is one that people
might not know i want to do that that's
what i've been telling myself i want to
learn how to dj and i want to get back
to my podcast this year i wrote those
down
dj and podcast yeah like learning how to
do you could be the manager slash tour
dj i'm not even told aj i want to be the
guy that does like this you know how
they behave
bizmarky come through oh yeah yeah
that's the piece like here come here yo
kp kawan prather shout out to kp kpg the
dj back see bro a bad see shaq come
through dj pain comfortable dj i want to
just like come
provide the vibe to a couple of dope
places i respect the whole house yeah i
just want i just want you know i respect
what you do you're a dj yeah shout out
to my guy joe vayne man go check him out
boom